began with tragedy in texas a city
worker hearing a call for help found a
tractor-trailer with at least 46 people
dead inside of it it's believed they
were migrants seeking a better life here
in the u.s another 16 people were taken
to hospitals including four children all
with heat related injuries authorities
describe some as hot to the touch it
happened in san antonio texas which is
no stranger to tragedies like this one
and it's where we find our omar
villafranca omar good morning three
people in custody this morning we know
that what else do we know at this hour
well good morning we don't know the
names uh or the ages of those who are
dead but we do know that of the 16
people taken to the hospital 12 adults
four children san antonio is not new to
these mass migrant deaths but the sheer
number here has officials done
tonight we are dealing with a horrific
human tragedy san antonio mayor ron
nirenberg urged compassion and prayers
as local officials described the grisly
scene that awaited first responders
yesterday evening the first 911 calls
came in just before six in the afternoon
local time after a city worker in the
area heard a cry for help coming from a
nearby tractor trailer
that witness then found the doors
partially opened with a number of
deceased individuals inside when
officials arrived on the scene the
enormity of the tragedy became clear
we're not supposed to open up a truck
and see
stacks of bodies in there
temperatures in the area yesterday
ranged from the high 90s to the low 100s
no signs of water in the vehicle it was
a refrigerated tractor trailer
but there was no visible working ac unit
on that rig
this is not the first migrant-related
tragedy to strike san antonio in recent
years back in 2017 10 migrants died
after they were found in a sweltering
semi-trailer near a local walmart but
the sheer number of dead in this latest
incident is once again shedding light on
a migrant crisis along the southern
border and the human smugglers who get
them there and beyond
already this fiscal year u.s customs and
border protection has recorded more than
1.5 million encounters in the southwest
nearly the same amount as all of 2021
we don't know where that trailer was
headed but we're just a few hundred
yards from i-35 interstate highway which
starts at the texas-mexico border and
goes all the way up to minnesota it is a
known smugglers room investigators with
department of homeland security are here
on the scene and they are now leading
this investigation nate
omar thank you